bon allez beaucoup pensent que depuis la
dernière fois les choses ont changé ah
oui radicalement vous avez vu dimanche
soir l'intervention oui j'ai que si
l'ère
françois lève le pied tout de suite
quand on a un air bag qui s'appelle jean
marc ayrault
a le but de l'airbag c qui regroupe sous
le choc pas l'inversé
mais ces périodes extrêmement bizarre on
l'a rolland président et au premier
ministre harlem désir premier secrétaire
quand même désir qui a été élu prg je
respecte vers l'inventeur du pin's pour
myope tu sais le truc enfin je moi j'ai
longtemps pensé que la grosse mode dingo
là c'était comme pour le ruban rouge du
sida tu vois sauf que c'était pour
l'hépatite
heureusement en tout cas qui s'appelle
harlem désir quoi moi ça c'est un prénom
qui comme quoi c'est pas c'est pas à
l'ump vous avez passez à commencer par
un mec qui s'appelle ni blasé
mais ça ça c'est de la petite cuisine
germanopratine saas intéressent personne
honnêtement ce qui compte c'est qu'on
arrête de l'ennuyer il faut arrêter de
l'ennui et kouassi à chaque fois qu'ils
s'énervent il crée un impôt enfin moi je
peux pas
prêt que l'état va gagner 30 milliards
impressionnant j'espère qu'il va
s'appliquer les 75% pour voir comme ça
fait mal
en tout cas moi je suis content que les
75 % concernent les artistes vraiment je
trouve ça comme ça les jours où j'ai pas
d'inspiration au travail je me dis moi
je fais au moins chier le fisc mais
attention il a de grandes ambitions ça
je veux pas juger inverser la courbe du
chômage en un an sans croissance
au moins on tient une info solide quoi à
l'elysée les salles de shoot fonctionne
à plein tube
[Applaudissements]
on a tout essayé pour l'emploi seront là
tout essayé relancer l'emploi relancer
la croissance diminuer les impôts
augmenter les impôts enfin il reste quoi
à part trucider les chômeurs moi je vois
pas trop le toit ou les pousser à
l'expatriation ça leur fera un réflexe
de riches au moins un truc en commun je
vais pas partir en belgique n'ont pas
envie de bucarest ça c'est
quoi
je me demandais ce qu'il ya dans le
métro de bucarest des mendiants français
qui interprète des tubes en roumain
bon ça c'est chasser la gauche après à
droite à l'ump on n'a pas beaucoup
d'imagination franchement j'ai vu que
xavier bertrand propose une candidature
générationnel nkm est le maire quelque
chose comme attelage
la polytechnicienne le normalien et
l'agent d'assurances n'ont ils rien
films de sergio leone
la matheuse le littéraire et
l'escroquerie
[Applaudissements]
quant à vous vous en sommes vraiment le
malin on tique ap awan anticapitaliste
anticapitaliste un type qui a au moins
une fois dans sa vie distribuer une
enveloppe à bettencourt
qu'est ce que va prendre la pauvre
qu'est ce qu'on va prendre une rentière
mais bon c'est quoi un rentier c'est
quoi un rentier c'est un chômeur qui a
l'élégance ne pas demander une
allocation
non mais oui il faut réfléchir quoi
merde pas m'énerver après l économie
arnaud va partir en belgique alors tout
le monde qui couine ah ouais mais
bernard arnault est parti en belgique
pour des raisons financières
heureusement on va partir pour le climat
ou les paysages
pas les paysages belge le paysage belge
le jour où la terre se désinfecte si
elle a un masque mortuaire c'est la
belgique
tu m'étonnes que napoléon et perdu à
waterloo pour moi il est arrivé là bas
il a vu le truc jura non j'ai pas envie
de lui
faire la guerre avec la chanson de aba
dans la tête tout le temps ou pas
mais je me disais quand on pense que
l'homme le plus riche de france doit
s'exiler en belgique alors que des
retraités appellent smicard s'expatrient
au maroc
où est la logique quoi olivier
explique-moi feu bah ouais et bernard
est fragile bernard est fragile porter
plainte par lieu de porter plainte il
aurait mieux fait de racheter libe
avec une ligne éditoriale un peu sévère
comme ça pour faire chier les gauchistes
qui veulent un truc qui ferait passer le
figaro pour un journal anarchiste
t'imagines la première une la photo de
copé
avec le titre peut-on faire confiance
un mou
ce que vous oubliez besancenot qui sont
les clients de lvmh accuse les riches
vous croyez vraiment que la caissière de
monoprix râler moyen de lâcher mille
balles dans un cul de wotan et
alors on veut mettre à la porte un type
qui ponctionne les risques comme
incroyable car au lieu de stigmatiser ce
pauvre homme il faut se renseigner un
peu mais j'ai vu chiffre d'affaires de
lvmh 20 milliards par an 20 milliards
qui prend aux 90 % à l'international
donc il prend chez les riches en plus
étranger si c'est pas un patriote moi je
sais pas
non arnaud c'est quand même le dalaï
lama du sac à pof
pendant ce temps hollande joue au curé
économique pas forcément en force de
visiter les usines pour dire désolé on
peut rien faire c'est devenu une sorte
de donneurs deux derniers sacrements
industriel qu un bon ouvrier confesser
ses péchés avant d'aller au chômage
heureusement qu'il ya des techniques
pour faire oublier qu'on peut rien faire
les réformes dont tout le monde se fout
en ce moment si tu bosses chez psa les
seuls gens qui ont un peu d'espoir c'est
les homos avec un projet de mariage
je me disais au prochain plan social il
va proposer quoi ça va être quoi le
gimmick la possibilité pour les enfants
d'adopter les parents
le droit opposable au cancer
le classement du vélib comme espèce
protégée
mais on laisse tomber je sais c'est la
semaine il faut finir avec un truc un
peu sympathique une bonne nouvelle dsk
porte plainte aussi oui je comprends
imagine trois couvertures avec la même
femme
atteinte à la réputation polygame
alors pas belle la vie pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu